i am moyra franklin
today is october 19th 1899.
why do you think they're all here
they're all running away from something
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
about the new teaser trailer for 1899
which i'm not really surprised to say
looks super intriguing this is husband
and wife director writer duo baron beau
udar and yancha frieza's follow-up to
one of my all-time favorites dark as the
name suggests we do go back in time to
the year 1899 and every indication is
that we'll stay there rather than
jumping around to different time periods
personally i'm good with that this team
did such a fantastic job with time
travel that i'm really excited to see
what else they come up with and from the
looks of this teaser there will be some
strange and mysterious stuff going on
beau and yancha emphasized this saying
we don't repeat ourselves we really hate
that but it's going to be a fun puzzle
for the audience we're going back to our
mystery roots all the passengers on the
ship are traveling with dark secrets
that they don't want to get out it's
built like a puzzle again knowing that
we did dark everyone can be assured that
this is going to be something weird and
wild and crazy considering this is the
first season of a show that we don't
know much about most of the analysis
amounts to hey this looks really cool
but there are a few things that jumped
out at me right away this is a large
ensemble cast and it cycles through them
rather quickly so i appreciated stranger
jonas's familiar face and the
recognizable sounds of ben frost's score
to carry us along the sound here feels
connected to the atmosphere of dark
while still sounding like something
brand new the next thing that stood out
is that all the dialogue is in english
which may have seemed welcome to some
viewers who aren't used to reading
subtitles but the show is actually
multilingual in interviews the creators
have stated that being true to cultures
and languages was very important and
they wanted a truly european show with a
mixed cast from different countries this
makes for an interesting setup since
communication problems are built in and
in their words at its heart is the
question of what unites us and what
divides us and how fear can be a trigger
for the latter so what are we looking at
here the official log line from netflix
reads 1899 a migrant steam ship heads
west to leave the old continent the
passengers a mixed bag of european
origins united by their hopes and dreams
for the new century and their future
abroad but their journey takes an
unexpected turn when they discover
another migrant ship a drift on open sea
what they will find on board will turn
their passage to the promised land into
a horrifying nightmare the ship they're
on which you see at the beginning is
called the kerberos and the one that
went missing is the prometheus you learn
that from a newspaper that emily
beatham's character mara franklin is
holding up kerberos is from greek
mythology and is referred to as the
hound of hades it's a multi-headed dog
that guards the gates of the underworld
to prevent the dead from leaving
prometheus is also from myth and is best
known for defying the gods by stealing
fire from them and giving it to humanity
in the form of technology knowledge and
more generally civilization according to
that article the prometheus had been
missing for four months and there's
mention of the devil's triangle or
bermuda triangle under the photo but you
can't really make out the paragraph text
mara looking at herself in the mirror
and saying her name and the date makes
it seem like she might be losing track
of reality or her memories the newspaper
could be a reference point for her it is
the southampton post and she's english
she's got some very noticeable marks on
her wrist that appear to be from
struggling against restraints there's a
quick shot of someone doing just that
that i don't know how to describe other
than to say that it has asylum vibes
we see a few shots of her with other
first class passengers including this
hypnotic looking one where they all sip
their tea at the same time and we see
the captain addressing them all in that
same dining area he's a german named ike
larson and played by the stranger
andreas peachman according to the
character description he remains strange
and mysterious to his crew he's not only
addicted to alcohol but also has a very
dark secret and there's this shot later
that could be him looking at a fire that
takes place away from the ship so this
could be from his past and that might be
the dark secret they're referencing
there's one other shot that i initially
thought was him with the lower class
passengers where it looks like they're
praying i went back and looked at the
previous teaser and noticed it was a
different bearded character and so that
could also be the person that's looking
at the fire it's interesting that
there's a clergyman and that they're
turning to faith there is another priest
on board who's with the first class
passengers but we don't see them doing
anything like that in this teaser later
we see quite a few of these steerage
class characters holding lanterns and
looking out into the distance from the
deck
there's another behind the scenes video
they put out where both said dark was
not about action at all but this is
really an action show with a lot of
violence beating running screaming and
you see that throughout the official
teaser and there's some extra filming
shots in the second video i imagine this
is either a conflict with the prometheus
when they encounter that or they turn on
each other in relation to what they find
on it that would seem to connect to the
phrase what is lost will be found from
the postcard and that could also relate
to their secrets and the things they're
trying to keep from each other it seems
like they're trying to be careful not to
give too much away but all of this does
look tense because of the fact that
they're on a ship together on the open
sea
throughout this trailer you see these
triangles with a line through them
they're usually pointing down and that's
the alchemical symbol for earth and if
it's flipped up it would be air these
appear to be everywhere and if you're
wondering the symbols for fire and water
are just normal triangles without the
line like you see in this image and on
the telegraph ticker tape
there's no explanation behind the symbol
at this point and to me it feels like it
could be connected to a secret society
or something along those lines what they
believe in who are the members and what
they're trying to do are all mysteries
once you notice the symbol you can find
it everywhere even on some of the
clothing from the photo they released
months ago but that's only on two
characters the captain and this woman
who's wearing a green dress that we see
sitting at a table with mara the fact
that it's on her dress makes it appear
that she's either a true believer or
someone important in relation to this
symbol and what it represents most of
the images that evoke mystery feature
this image there's a tattoo behind
someone's ear that another character is
looking at there's an ornate looking
robe that has it on the back that i
think we see the character named ling yi
wearing in this shot where she's holding
a fan this is a little confusing because
it looks like a kimono to my untrained
eyes but the name yi sounds chinese
either way she stands out from the other
passengers who are european in origin
and there's one weird shot of her
standing in front of a door where we see
some of them who seem to be walking
towards it there are shots of buttons
with triangles and a red light between
them and i mentioned the telegraph
machine that was printing them out i
think that is connected to this
mechanical device which i think is a
spark gap transmitter which was a real
thing used to transmit radio waves in
that time period i should mention that
there was a pre-teaser they put out a
week ago where they used morse code to
make the announcement that this trailer
was coming out this week it was a neat
little gimmick and i assumed the images
there were all teasing what we see in
this one but there are quite a few that
aren't included and i've tried to point
those out as they came up
a couple that i haven't mentioned yet
might be on the prometheus after they
discover it you see some of the
passengers and the captain walking
around with lanterns and everything
looks destroyed and deserted there are
also a bunch of creepy looking kids a
couple of which might die or be killed
based on what we see here this trailer
opens with one placing this pyramid on
the carpet from under the table and that
was in a child's hand in the pre-teaser
there's also a shot there where a woman
is holding a candle up to a child's face
and sort of blocking and unblocking the
flame which gives the sense that he's
catatonic or something like that he's
not responding to the flame there's also
a pregnant passenger on board who looks
conflicted in most of the shots that we
see her in as the voiceover tells us
that all of the passengers are running
from something we see her running away
from something literally in the forest
and i do like this idea of characters
being mysterious when we first meet them
and getting to know things about them
through flashbacks that the other
passengers won't be aware of this should
provide fertile ground for speculation
as to why they're making choices and
doing things in the middle of whatever
crisis they find themselves in and there
is a shot of this pregnant woman loading
a shotgun that makes you wonder if she's
looking for revenge the last two shots i
want to talk about are one where someone
is moving their finger towards something
black that appears to be reacting it's a
vague description i know but that's what
you see it almost looks like it's
growing to reach the finger and looks
really otherworldly the other one is
this closing shot where the ship is
being pulled towards this giant
whirlpool it's a fantastic overhead shot
and it looks as though there's lightning
under the waves and i can't wait to see
what's going on here statements like the
passengers are all running from
something and nothing is as it seems
convince me that we're in for a wild
ride and the closing moments you hear
anton lesser's voice say people are
oblivious to reality they only see what
they want to see when all they have to
do is shift their perspective to see the
full scope of things that voice might
sound familiar as kai burns from game of
thrones and his character doesn't show
up in either teaser but we do see him
wearing a jacket with the triangles on
his collar in the behind the scenes
video so perceptions of reality will be
involved we can see that there's going
to be strange happenings on this ship
and they say it will be a visually
stunning odyssey and in that behind the
scenes video they explain more about the
volume technology they use to film it
this is still pretty new and from what
we see in these trailers it all looks
like it came off looking pretty
realistic and i've already talked about
that technology and how it works and
what they built in my last 1899 videos
so i'll just leave a link for that here
for me i'd watch anything the duo behind
dark makes and this looks to be up to my
expectations there's no release date
mentioned yet and i've seen a lot of
guesses that it might be on october 19th
since mara mentions that date in the
teaser dark did release on dates that
were related to its story but as a first
season this state doesn't really have
any importance yet other than it was
mentioned here i've also seen that
someone found the date november 24th in
the code of one of netflix's pages but
that isn't confirmed as the date either
it has been said it'll be out in autumn
winter so either one of those dates
could turn out to be close there are
eight episodes in the first season and i
do believe it's intended to be a
multi-season affair i think i remember
reading it would likely be three seasons
total but i couldn't find anything to
back that up while i was putting this
together and i think that's a good place
to bring this to an end
let me know what you thought about the
teaser and what you're most excited
about for this new series what are you
speculating about what are your theories
and do you think this looks like it'll
be as memorable as dark was please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon